to look back on here Oh some of your
best hair moments even I was seducing
Sara Lance and you have to that's the
haircut you needed he looks so sweet
Playboy Stephen you know and one of many
wigs what I see here is a hairline that
couldn't exist truly in real life thou
shalt not pass
those the eyes are still right there
right that's blue steel baby it's like
I've been through some stuff I don't
know I can't plate this one I can't
place it
Stephen I think you look the hottest
with this hair no okay yeah I like that
too oh I like that short hair you don't
you don't want to mess with a dude with
short hair new bachelor legends of the
fall Brad Pitt kind of thing like Chord
Overstreet and Glee
oh that's smooth Big Daddy right there
that's the guy I met I fell in love with
right there that's my boo boo wild
politician hair yeah I just think it's
really hot the hair from castaway that
Tom Hanks had where's Wilson and of
course Noah look at the Isaac his steely
eyes in the and the hair he knows
something to be seen again soon
you